do you have any idea when you're gonna  drop  well the deluxe obviously is coming soon  i'm assuming yeah  um no no specific date but i plan to  drop it  late october early november besides russ  is there going to be any other features  on the deluxe there's got to be right  yeah like who  man just don't run out there bruh i mean  i already mentioned his name earlier but  you mentioned his name earlier yeah  i still want people to anticipate oh you  tell my tiger yeah but i still want  people to anticipate me even doing  features wait so tiger's gonna be on  your deluxe  fire shout out to tyga man  that's lit yo he's been he'd be you know  i tapped in man  now yeah tiger got his ears to the  streets i was crazy i wasn't expecting  for him to even  know who i was that's crazy